une vidéo protection piloté par seine et
yvelines numériques pour les communes et
intercommunalités le projet en cours
d'élaboration par le syndicat mixte un
sujet sur lequel est engagé le
conseiller départemental yvelinois
patrick stefanini ce syndicat va pouvoir
intervenir auprès des communes à leur
demande à la fois pour les aider
financièrement à acquérir à installer et
à maintenir les matériels mais également
seine et yvelines numériques pourra
faire du visionnage pour le compte des
communes et du visionnage h 24
comme ce syndicat le fait déjà pour le
compte du département sur les bâtiments
départementaux aujourd'hui le projet est
en cours de conception les membres de
senna yvelines numériques consulte les
maires et élus intercommunaux c'était le
cas lors de cette conférence organisée
le jeudi 21 octobre à la ferme du manet
objectif final mettre en place des
centres de supervision sur le territoire
maire de cheuvreux à néry le pallec
présentes lors de cette matinée est
intéressé par la démarche
l'évolution législative va vraiment
permettre ça en s'appuyant sur des
dispositifs qui sont mutualisés à
beaucoup plus grande échelle donc les
moyens du département avec avec son bras
armé le syndicat seine yvelines
numériques et d'être beaucoup plus dans
une action préventive que dans une
action répressive les centres de
supervision serait directement en
relation avec les polices municipales
nationale et la gendarmerie une phase
opérationnelle pourrait être lancée
l'année prochaine sur des communes ou
intercommunalités des yvelines